hey guys and welcome back to grizzly
Valley today is a bit of a filler
episode since I didn't really work on
anything groundbreaking or iconic just
really had to work on some smaller
things around this area specifically
which means fun a lot of path work and
adding some details around that and a
couple smaller houses actually trying to
somewhat build a pagoda but that's
something I really need to get back to
and that the same goes for the Japanese
theme as well but also I'll be working
on some of the lighting in this area and
it's really a filler episode in that
sense since nothing really big is being
done and I also don't really feel like I
did really anything new in this episode
it's sort of just it's something which I
had to do just to make this entire park
feel like an actual Park and actually be
able to finish the park and not just go
over the things that are most fun or
interesting to build a look at but that
said there are a couple of things that I
sort of want to talk about in the
context of this entire video series in
general I get a lot of questions about
whether I'll actually give a POV of the
the nameless cow so actually the
nameless Alpine Coaster which goes up
the mountain and I have to say I'm not
going to get a POV of that anytime soon
because at the moment the roller-coaster
isn't even finished yet and I have plans
to just like I pretty much always do
just save the POV s and the more
cinematic shots or for at the end of
this park when it's all done and
basically I don't want to spoil the
right before it's entirely done and it's
also something which is easier for me
since I just like to focus on building
the park for now and just show it off
when it's actually done or when I feel
like it's actually worth showing off and
until that time I'll just be working on
this and still be making time-lapse
videos but I don't quite want to show
the actual point of view quite yet so
that's about that and something which I
should also really talk about is my
upload rate I as much as I wish I could
keep it as much as I used to when I had
vacation I really don't have that much
time to work on this
and so my upload rate won't be that
great and besides I don't want to play
the game just for recording since I've
been doing that for a couple past
episodes of this series or at least
these two ones for Japan and I really
feel like I just want to take a bit more
time as well in between the episodes to
try different things and see how certain
things really work and if I really want
to build in a general style as I'm
planning basically just try what I want
to build before I actually build it and
get some ideas and basically some tests
of how objects can work together and how
I want to compose stuff just because I
would rather have episodes way less
frequently then have them more
frequently but still not feel too great
about my Park myself so that's basically
about that because especially when it
comes to the Japanese area I am I am
actually quite happy with the overall
layouts and how it all sort of comes
together but there are just different
points which I'm really insecure about
how this part it's actually going to
work out and it's mainly about the
detailing of it and the roofs and
speaking of that something which also
makes this episode sort of a filler
episode is that I'll still keep the
Japanese area the way it is at the
moment but in the next episode I'll
actually give it a bit of a makeover
since and this is something which I
should probably also address in the next
video as well but Skookum onna on Chagas
world actually had the amazing idea to
put signs on the roofs to avoid their
blueness which is definitely my worst
complaints about not really just the
game limitations in general but also the
Japanese area the fact that all roofs
are blue inevitably makes everything
look very much the same even if you use
different styles or different details
around it and this was also really my
biggest gripe with the Japanese area
because as much as I like to focus on at
least composing the area in general and
making these buildings they all end up
having blue roofs which not only is it
incredibly unrealistic for Japanese
buildings it also just makes everything
look so very much the same since the
roof colors are exactly the same as the
alpine area as well so that's something
which are actually messed with in the
next episode
in that sense this episode feels a bit
over one of one anyway these buildings
over here I wanted to quickly have just
as a way of having some restaurants I'm
trying to from this point onwards at
least incorporate restaurants some
what's functionally in the sense that I
do want to use some function or stalls
and so that at least people can buy
stuff this not only really goes for
restaurants bathrooms is the same story
but sort of build around that to make it
seem like more of a realistic building
so in this case I really figured this
would be a nice hat shop and
realistically the hat shop would pretty
much
occupy the entire building or probably
not just be a hat shop but a general
souvenir shop or gift shop for the
coaster it could even be but in this
case I obviously had to have that small
store and I really figured best way to
sort of get that in there is have that
small site building in between them
where I could actually connect the path
to it without having to worry about
issues of people walking through the
plans here like that but also still make
it seem like the building is somewhat
functional so that's the idea behind
this and building wise they're generally
a bit of the typical Japanese small
houses that you see in larger cities or
the old largest cities that is and this
is also the style which I do want to
keep more in the rest of the Japanese
section since it's probably just the
most feasible style to do for such a
large area since it just allows for some
smaller houses and different rotations
as opposed to some very great like
temple way of laying out your Park which
I do have to say actually I really need
to thank everybody who actually sent me
some suggestions of real-life parks to
look at I completely forgot about Port
Aventura having a Asian section same
goes for phantasialand but that's a bit
harder because it's really just the
hotel and especially poison Ventura was
actually a pretty good inspiration or a
thing to look at but I actually wanted
to move away from that type of layouts
since it's very great like very much all
in straight lines which is what you do
see in Japanese temples which
have a square wall around it and have
all the buildings in a very grid like
layouts and I really wanted to avoid
that here and try to make this area much
more dynamic and with many small paths
that curve everywhere and rockwork and
flat right in between them so pretty
much the polar opposite of how you would
see a more temple like area being laid
out and that's why I do want to avoid
that style in favor of going for any
more small house ish type of
architecture in this general area and
the same goes for the layout of this
part of the park and I really hope to
maybe try some different things with
that because at this episode one of the
things which I felt made it a bit stale
is the fact that nothing really new gets
done in terms of what I'm actually
making and it felt the same way for
building it in the sense that I was
really just doing what I was already
used to with making the station of this
area which even though it was sort of
never change a winning team idea I
wanted to move away from that because
I've really felt myself doing something
which I was accustomed to which is what
I actually want to completely avoid with
this park because I really just want to
experiment with stuff and try new things
all the time so in that sense this
really felt like strolling in a way that
I was thinking well I'm doing something
which I technically already did in that
kind of sense and when it compared that
feeling to why I was building the pagoda
over here it's completely different
since the pagoda is much more
experimental but I also feel it failed
in the end in a certain way and I should
probably explain why because it's a
pretty hard thing to say really to
myself but it's because I think the
pagoda in general well it was somewhat
successful and turned out pretty good I
think for the limitations that I thought
of myself at the time it really didn't
come out too realistic and this mainly
due to the fact that the roof just
doesn't work the way it should really
since the only way I thought I could get
out of the lack of corner roof pieces
which is pretty bad at this point and I
really didn't want to use the Spanish
tile since that obviously pretty
much broke the theme I did tried at some
point but that didn't work very well
I do so I really didn't want to do that
but there aren't any other corner roof
pieces especially not any ones that are
look somewhat Asian and I didn't find
really any way to combine other pieces
to actually make a corner roof so I
decided well hopefully it might be okay
to stack some different roofs to at
least get the same shape as a pagoda and
this is where I feel it failed because
even though it still has the same shape
as a real pagoda it just doesn't have
any of the details or any of the actual
shape of it and I really felt in the end
it turned out as a blocky sort of Fats
pagoda which is not entirely what I was
looking for and something which I'll
actually improve in the next episode and
in that sense I feel like this episode
is only half of the story of something
which I want to finish in the next
episode regardless though I should
probably still do a bit of an
introduction to this building and I
probably shouldn't be depressed me all
this episode so basically this isn't a
pagoda sort of inspired by the hockey ji
temple in Japan which is a three storey
pagoda which I wanted to go for a three
storey pagoda basically because I really
felt a five storey pagoda Wow somewhat
feasible in this context would probably
look better on its own but not fit as
well in this environment I've really
wanted to picture a pagoda in this
corner as not really just the
centerpiece to what you see from the
plaza but also as something which makes
the lift Hill look larger and even
daunting that it probably already looks
in the background and just by having a
three storey pagoda which even though it
seems more impressive on itself than the
buildings around it and it certainly
still is the highest building in the
area the lift Hill sort of still looms
over it in the background and it's still
quite a bit higher than this pagoda and
with that I really wanted to get the
idea that you if you would look from the
plaza in front of it you have the pagoda
with in the background very clearly the
lift Hill which just because of having a
smaller pagoda in front of its we look
larger even though it isn't even that
large of a rollercoaster so it was more
or less for the composition of this
entire area rather than for the pagoda
itself that I wanted to go for a three
storey pagoda which I do frankly like
less than five storey pagoda and when it
comes to four or six storey pagodas
there was a not really a thing because
you don't use the number four or six in
your stories of pagodas or at least for
this type of pagoda because there are
definitely different types it's unusual
to have an odd know an even number for
the amount of stories not to say unusual
it's just completely out of the
questions you have that so that's why I
decided to go with the three storey
pagoda in the end and the Hakka G is I
think the oldest three storey pagoda in
Japan and it's pretty simple to do as
well as since it's the most feasible
just by the use of materials it's not
very complicated in terms of details yet
and it doesn't have the Redwood color
that some pakodas have so in terms of
that it's definitely also the most
feasible and I really felt it's the type
of design which I wanted to have here so
that's why I took a lot of inspiration
from it though in the end it's obviously
not exactly the same since that was more
or less input and impossible and I also
wanted to raise this a little bit higher
than pagodas usually have their base
just to have this bit of decoration
around it with rock work and foliage and
just have a bit more play with different
heights especially since we're we still
don't have terraforming in the game and
can't really mess with that I really
figured this is at least some easy way
to make sure that there are different
heights of paths within the park which
makes it all look at least a little bit
less boring and in the end the real
purpose of this episode was just to
dress up this area bits so that I could
more or less move on so yeah and in that
regard I am quite happy with how it
turned out but do remember that this is
more or less just half of the story not
to mention that probably in just a
couple of weeks and definitely far ahead
in the future I'll definitely look back
on this Park and think well that totally
sucks no idea how we used to be happy
with that at some point in time
because we're still so early in this
game and there's still so many ideas
that nobody has got yet and still so
much to try so while that may seem as an
excuse to not make things as good as I
may be good I would actually like to do
the opposite and try to make the best of
the things that we have at the moment
and at least push forward a little bit
even if in the future at some point
we'll just look back and laugh at this
at least for now I think it's fun and
probably for the best to try some more
stuff than just sit with the stuff that
we have at the moment so I definitely
want to get a bit more experimental from
this point onward and also already want
to go back to the other sections of the
park like some of the Alpine buildings
which I built in the first couple of
episodes which looking back at this
point in time I or I already feel yeah
that could be quite a bit better so even
at this point in time I do want to get
back to certain areas and improve some
stuff like especially the path work and
many of the detailing around here isn't
to create the overall layout of this
area I am definitely happy with but I
just can't stop tinkering with small
details and discovering little new ways
to use objects and I think that's
something which I've been sort of
missing out on in this episode but I did
also want to do a bit of lighting
especially since the roller-coaster over
here wasn't entirely lit up yet and this
especially goes for spotlights I didn't
put any spotlights on these supports or
other parts of the track yet and I was
really missing some lanterns here and
there
and since nighttime is not just such a
crucial parts of the game I think it's
also one of the most beautiful parts I
really wanted to make sure to put some
extra efforts in making sure this entire
thing is well lit and the same really
goes for the Asian buildings here and
something which I've always wanted to
try but haven't had the chance to try it
actually until this point in time was to
mix the different colour lights
something which I heard was that they do
mix so if you do get red lights and
yellow lights that in your gets an
orange light colour if you put them next
to each other which actually works which
is actually really cool so I wanted to
make this area at
light up a bit but also feel it make it
feel a bit warm by enemies yellow and
red colors instead of making everything
feel so very cold with just white
spotlights which also very easily seem
like they are way too bright a problem
which you don't as quickly have with red
or yellow lights so that's really does
and that's also basically it for this
episode so thank you guys for watching
is bit over one-off episode and in the
next one I'll be trying to do some more
new stuff new restaurants some flat
rides and also redo this area in general
so it yeah thank you guys for watching
I'll see you guys later